foreign
the reason we have movements right now
among a lot of young people on social
media that's called the anti-work
movement is because they've never been
taught real financial literacy because
this young man you take this question
right here and he begins to understand
what we just said to him he begins to
tell us money what to do the budget as
Dave just laid out here's what happens
individual responsibility flourishes
when you get taught that you can have
enough money but this anti-work movement
all this junk that's out there is coming
from young people who've never been
taught how to manage their money and
thus they don't have enough and then
they begin to say I work too hard I
don't have enough money I want the
government to supply me the money and
and I'm not trying to make this
political because it's not it's actually
sociological when you understand how to
handle money as a young person with what
we teach in financial literacy month and
everything we're doing control your
destiny they if you get off your little
butt and then they become hard workers
because they go I like what money allow
allows me to do I can be generous I can
be helpful I can be calm I don't have to
be pissed off all the time that's true
right you know it's just this is all
goes together see I thought the
anti-work movement was because College
professors were students of Karl Marx
and had passed that along to college
students and reinforced the fact that
they got a participation trophy instead
of keeping score when they were playing
soccer and they were sick well you just
nailed the two other reasons right but
the reasons those message stick is
because when you don't have any money
and you're broke those messages make
more sense yeah but to somebody who's
got money you go what are you talking
about that's a pay cut 55 years old you
know it's more fun to score there's that
you just do right I mean you don't have
to be a you don't have to be a
psychologist to figure this one out you
smile more when you score than when you
don't score so go score that's what work
is it's score go to score it's what it
is just go score yeah go put the ball in
the hoop man that's what you do right
and and you're going to have more joy
and more dignity and more choices when
you do that now Alex has not got that
problem he's a guy asking a question on
this that's right he's a great young man
and so I mean we got a lot of great
young people out there that's right but
we do have a group of participation
trophy graduates that's exactly our
intent on making mediocrity their goal
and uh it's a problem it is and by the
way this is what leads to credit card
debt at an all-time high student loans
all-time high I've got to rely on
somebody else to give me money so that I
can get the life I want and that is
counterintuitive and it leads to record
numbers of 28 year olds living in their
mother's basement
seven million men not working because
they don't like their job staff and as
the lady on CBS news that said the other
day that's highly unattractive
that's right hard to get a date yeah
it's true it's true you don't feel real
eligible because you're not right he's a
dreamer Daddy yeah that's right he is
that's all he does that's right yeah it
means you're gonna live in my basement
you're dating a dreamer oh God help me
yeah I'd love for you to say he's a doer
please tell me he's a doer yes he has
Big Dreams and he's doing things to make
those dreams come true that I like I
like that a lot yeah see this is highly
attractive you know turns out mediocrity
is really kind of smelly well it's
miserable they can try to put another
label on it but a person who's leaving
exactly beating the man by being a
communist yeah well you'll notice that
anybody who says these kind of things on
social media is always angry I tell you
what you never see an angry capitalist
an angry person with a lot of money and
options you see anger where I feel
limited and they start by being limited
financially because we don't teach
Financial financial literacy Ramsey
Solutions does that's why we're in
schools uh but if we don't teach the
this then what happens is they come
through the system Dave and the system
tells them you need a credit card so
that you have a backup plan you need to
get a student you need a credit score
two hundred thousand dollars in debt to
get a degree in left-handed puppets so
you can be successful and you can be a
barista right oh by the way the only
people winning in that system are the
people given the loans and the credit
cards interestingly enough they're the
ones that are winning big credit cards
at an all-time I'm going to stick it to
the man I'm gonna make sure he gets
really rich
right right and if they're upset against
rich people the people ought to be a set
against are they are the financial
purveyors of all of the mediocrity and
frustration in your life see that's the
game you want to be mad at somebody it's
the people who make really awesome
commercials selling your credit card
they're the best commercials on TV
here's the thing if your job sucks
I mean you're not in Russia no just go
get another one that's right if your
boss sucks right get you another one
that's exactly right well here's this
hard yeah well the gig economy is
exploding right now Dave freelance work
people can get out of debt faster we've
had nurses call in on this program I
don't like what Walmart pays that's
right don't work then go work somewhere
else uh We've we got an unbelievable job
economy right now 3.6 Unemployment uh my
weight was never to work in McDonald's
it was never a goal of mine yeah that's
yeah unless it's the one by the way
that's the one I own in Saint Thomas but
right you know no thank you right and
that's no one's goal but see we to live
in a world now where you don't have to
go work at McDonald's you can go start
your own business online today I I never
had to that's the point I know I used to
cut grass and I my buddies this was a
thousand years ago when dinosaurs roamed
the Earth my buddies were making a
dollar 65 minimum wage
wow this is how long ago it was true
story I was 12 years old and I cut grass
for three dollars for a yard and I
figured out I could cut the grass in one
hour so I was making double what my
buddies were making as Whopper floppers
so I've never been held to the standard
of I am forced to do something yes and
you aren't either you can choose to go
do anything you want to do boys and
girls this is still America that's right
it's weirder America than ever before
but it's still America